à 3 mois de grossesse l'embryon mesure
plus ou moins 7 cm il y a une petite
excroissance pour la tête et la peau est
un peu fripée ce qui veut dire que c'est
le moment de sa vie ou un enfant
ressemble le plus à une bille de repos
je sais que ça peut paraître un petit
peu violent comme ça genre juste
préciser au cas où il y en aurait dans
la salle que bien évidemment je n'ai
rien contre les vitorpo
voilà moi-même j'ai des amis qui en ont
donc je n'ai rien contre les Peter faux
j'embrasse toutes celles qui sont dans
cette salle
non vous dites certainement c'est quand
même très déplacé de dire ça alors que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure que mon père
était dans la salle
non je voulais vous rassurer tout de
suite mon père quand je suis sur scène
il bande